foreign
[Music]
how big will the red Kong or orangegong
be in comparison to Godzilla and Kong in
the upcoming gxk the new Empire also
will this come be the reason why Kong
and Godzilla would fight again in the
new movie if so how would this happen so
we are going to answer these two
questions in detail well with a butt
load of speculation as well as a nut
load of fictional signs so let's get to
it
the teaser began with a behemoth-sized
ape titan perch on a throne surrounded
by bones and skeletons of numerous other
Titans the shot then pans out to reveal
Godzilla and Kong's skulls both
sparkling with their own colors one blue
and the other orange its design is
wonderful despite the fact that it is
essentially just a silhouette but close
inspection reveals that it is covered in
fur but not the grayish black first seen
in Kong but rather a reddish orange one
and it appears to be balding in some
spots indicating its old age it has two
very lengthy arms longer than Kongs
conforming my notion that this may be a
new super species or a subspecies its
spawns and hands are dark black while
its legs are only barely visible but
could we guessed that they are off a
similar coloration
in the last shot we saw a face of an ape
with red wall pain and red fur on its
sides that kind of looks like my
receding hairline the eyes however
shines a faint blue indicating that it
either has special powers from the
papausos or is undermine control
so what do we know about its size well
it is going to be a massive creature duh
an apex Titan size monster it definitely
won't be the size of any skull crawler
skull devil or Mothra as this would only
make it look cute in front of the two
superpowers this won't also create a
feeling of awe or a fear uncertainty and
doubt in the viewer's eyes we can
clearly say that it will be massive in
size definitely over 300 feet or 90
meters in the most minimum estimate but
we are going to tell you why this Titan
would be even taller than both the G-Man
and Kong so the only clue we have is his
position in the throne and the skeletons
of countless dead tired and super
species that litter the ground in front
of it if it is in fact the same place
that gong sat upon whilst entering his
ancestral home then this redcon would
absolutely be giant bigger than Kong way
bigger take my word for it but if this
is another place maybe his own home and
Throne then only the skeletons can tell
and the hardest part is this we do not
know which bone belongs to which that in
here since they are all in a mess
anyway our final estimate for him is
that he will most likely be taller than
both Kong and the Big G because reason
number one the premise or synopsis of
the movie states that they have to team
up Godzilla and Kong against an enemy
that threatens both of their existence
reason number two if he was the size of
Kong or standing at a similar height
then Kong will definitely be more
powerful owing to his more muscular
build therefore the orangakong or red
Kong should be at least tall enough so
that his lanky physique would prove to
be a considerable advantage in a fight
against both Titans especially gone
reason number three the bigger the
better what Mori wants that's reason
enough isn't it thus in my
extraordinarily humble opinion I would
say that the enemy Titan should stand at
roughly between 450 and 500 feet tall or
137 to 152 meters in height his weight
however well more than Kong but still
less than Godzilla because as a
mammalian Titan he wouldn't be that
heavy
and as for the second question how will
this enemy Dragon cause another battle
between come and Godzilla so this one is
purely speculation but we are going to
answer it nonetheless so first of all
this old Tyrant as we have theorized in
a previous video might have been the
reason behind the cause of the ancient
war between the Kongs and the Gojira
species he has the appearance of a
cunning and Sinister villain that is
both gold and calculative as well as
brutal and physically powerful but
before we get to it we should first
understand the relationship between Kong
and Godzilla post GVK so these two Apex
Titans went their own separate ways
after the battle against Mechagodzilla
it was sort of like a truce and an easy
peace treaty of sorts Godzilla would go
on ruling the Seas while Kong would
inherit his Old Kingdom in the hollow
Earth but these things are you know
always temporary and a slight
disturbance might very well lead to
another Clash of the Titans
so this red Kong although powerful
enough might not be that strong to take
on the two super species at once at the
same time or he might be cutting enough
as to not face them even alone
one-on-one when they are at full
strength so the red car might stir up
the old hatred by misleading both
tyrants into believing that one of them
broke the truth and therefore set off a
chain of events that would lead to a GVK
2.0
for Godzilla he might do a hit and run
tactic from afar and as he does look
like Coggin away at least from a
considerable distance or might have the
same sense this attack would start a new
compon for the G-Man in retaliation and
as for Kong the villain might use his
special abilities I'm guessing that he
has one or two due to the glowing eyes
owing that he might have the power
source in him so that he would use them
to trick The Big Ape into thinking
Godzilla has to use an atomic breath
either on him or the ones he care about
so both the Big G and Kong would go up
against one another in retaliation for a
thing that the red Kong did so he would
be watching from afar and waiting to
strike at the opportune moment to kill
both of them
yet going with the statement in the
synopsis at least a part of it the part
that says pitting the almighty Kong and
the Fearsome Godzilla against a colossal
undiscovered threat hidden within our
world it means that eventually both
Godzilla and Kong will team up to defeat
this red Kong or maybe another enemy
that controls him but all this is
unknown and it's all speculation
legendary I expect royalty if this was
ever to become true anyway the only way
we will know is if we see a full-on
trailer soon enough and if not then
until the movie is released so I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam